so last night we went to see the
assassins creed movie and I have one
question for you guys what did you think
of it ed you go first Spain is cool
Spanish obviously the past is the most
enticing thing about it one thing I
really did like is that how they all
spoke actual Spanish yeah I don't really
sort of that they didn't do that sheet
yeah didn't do a silly accent I'm
leaving west of the sub terrace and I
enjoy to the set designer sort of the
visual aesthetic of it all I think it
translated to film very well I really
enjoyed the action there's an amazing
chase sequence that goes for it felt
like a way for about 10 minutes and I
never got bored in it and I really
really enjoyed all of that and the
translation of the assassins movement
and all of that stuff to film wisdom
perfect so for those who don't know the
upcoming Assassin's Creed movie is
obviously based on the franchise but
it's a new story about this dude called
colum Lynch who is exploring the
memories of his ancestor I've Allah and
he learns more about the assassins in
the Templars and everything that's going
on with them I thought they did a really
good job of showing what an assassin is
through like their movement the park or
was really good i thought they they did
a really good job of showing how
assassin's attack there was a huge focus
on agility in gadgets and when it did
come to a one-on-one confrontation
whenever there was combat if it was
strength and endurance base they tend to
get taken out but it was more about
being clever and when it was about like
taking opportunities or finding like
different ways of engaging in combat
which is basically how the games go I
thought that was that was really well
done they and they stay very true to the
game I thought what yeah i really liked
all the different weapons they should
have showed off and i did like that
aspect of it but one thing i will say is
that I feel like the action scenes were
a bit too heavily edited for me
especially as someone who's played a lot
of Assassin's Creed games like I know
like the movement I kind of want to see
all that on camera but they tend to tend
it to sort of a cutaway and sort of the
payoff moments like they do like a cool
flip on a wall and go to punch some guy
and they cut immediately I didn't really
get that bump yeah but that's probably
just the personal opinion I kind of
liked what i was looking at it's a
gorgeous film the all the on location
stuff is really nice I think it's a step
up from what we've come to expect her
video
movies and the casting is great mm-hmm
the actors all did a really good job the
story's a tad lackluster I felt like it
was kind of I kept describing it as a
roller coaster of quality it really
comes up and it has these moments where
you're like oh my god this is so cool I
feel like it really did deliver bits and
pieces of that and then it would kind of
come down with like a little cheesy
tumble or just the payoff as you said
wouldn't be that yeah I didn't think the
dog was that cheesy there was certainly
a few cheesy lines um but I just thought
overall the story was a bit flat for me
was a bit dull there was no like solid
motivation for fast fenders character to
actually get into being an assassin or a
Templar or whatever or you know changes
opinions one way or the other like you
just kind of did it another thing with
the action scenes and the editing was
that it was so frantic that you didn't
actually actually see when threats were
coming to get them so then that chasing
that you mentioned that was really cool
I didn't see when enemies are coming to
swarm them they would just end up in
place and pick up new weapons like that
I had no idea existed yeah and all of a
sudden they'd be killing a bunch of
dudes who just happened to pop up yeah
that's all was a little confusing for me
as a counter to that I think that
because it was a chase scene dudes
popping up kind of made sense to me
because they were like didn't know what
was coming they didn't know they didn't
have a plan so when dudes would appear i
was like okay that seems to make sense
to me one of the things that kind of
annoyed me about the movie is actually
one of the things I really loved about
it had really interesting second and
third run characters like the people in
the modern day the other people who are
in this abstergo facility and also the
assassins from like back in Spain were
really interesting seeming characters
and they didn't get a lot of springtime
it really focused on Fassbender which
was fine because his character was
entertaining and charismatic but that
seems like a sort of a missed
opportunity they could have explored
more about those characters because I
wanted to know more they were
interesting enough that I wanted to be
told more about their stories but it
never quite reached them yeah especially
the female assassins in Spain she was a
really
cool character I really wish we knew
more about her and her motivations and
how she affected you know Fassbender
sort of Aguilar yeah so nice yeah as an
AC fan I think seeing the assassins
translate to the screen is interesting
yeah that I think overall I wouldn't
recommend seeing the movie like I
wouldn't recommend rushing out to see
the movie maybe go and see it on a cheap
shoes day I think I think it's worth
seeing in cinemas especially but I do
wonder if you're not an assassin's creed
then what are you going to get out of it
because it's it's kind of it like you
said the story I feel is very intricate
and you need to know a lot of things
from the series from the damn series
itself so I think if you're a fan of the
series go and see it I mean I think it's
definitely not like a Stella masterpiece
of action films but I think they did a
good job I think the visuals are good i
think it's the actors did a good job
yeah i think it's working and if
anything they've gotten the laura all
the way and now it's like any ubisoft
title second one because undoubtedly
gonna be better turtling get ready for
sequel after sequel a sequel because
best friend has already signed up for
like two or three is he really yeah well
at least one more ah but anyway that's
just our opinions let us know if you're
gonna go see this one and when you do
what you thought of it and we'll catch
you next time
you